to continue our coverage of the Supreme
Court's historic decision 5 - for
allowing gay marriage in the United
States so we've got Phil Mattingly our
political correspondent Phil tell us a
little bit more about the political
ramifications of this vote the
president's gonna be talking at 11:00 so
he's gonna be very happy about this we
talked about the Republicans a little
bit
what is this different Democrats in 2016
this is a coalition that Hillary Clinton
has made a very concerted effort to
reach out to over the last six months
and the coalition as we've seen both in
this case particularly in their ability
to kind of round up public support and
change in many cases public support for
this but also in their effort to align
with businesses this coalition of LGBT
is extremely effective they're great
organizing and organizing and getting
out the vote for Democrats it wasn't
like this was a difficult issue to begin
with except for this is an issue that
will help the candidate all three of
whom all three of the major ones Bernie
Sanders Governor Martin O'Malley and
Hillary Clinton are all on board with
this
this allows them to kind of make this a
bigger issue one thing we did already
see I'm on all of Hillary Clinton's
fundraising lists and all of her list
and supporter list in general she has
already sent a email out to gather names
and data in support of this they are
using this they waited all of about 10
minutes to use this as a exercise for
their own campaign and so what you look
is you look for them to find areas that
motivate their people and motivate their
base and this is certainly one of them
and she's already trying to capitalize
on this so the analytics team is working
overtime right now immediately okay to
what extent is Hillary Clinton a late
comer playing catch-up to the changes in
in public opinion the way that the
president was I mean the president as
you mentioned earlier kind of turned his
changes mind
some might say abruptly over the last
couple of years was Hillary Clinton
always in support of gay marriage or did
she to kind of take her position more
strongly after the tide of public
opinion change she took her position
more strongly after the tide of public
to National Democratic politicians were
late comers on this compared to the
remainder compared to the rest of the
party okay and the expectation was if
you went back to 2008 and again this
just underscores how
this has changed no national democratic
politician in 2008 thought they could
win a general election coming out on
this issue and the polling actually
backed that up I don't have it
specifically in front of me right now
but and we're looking at the time in
2007 and 2008 you're looking at polling
where this was not this this was an
underwater issue you did not want to
touch this you would talk about the
ability for people to love one another
but when it came to marriage this was a
different possibly civil unions but when
he came to marriage you kept away from
it that has all changed really in the
last two years when I show you some
comments by at least one of the
Republican contenders
you've got Jeb Bush coming out and well
giving his thoughts what you're seeing
right now is one Republicans on Capitol
Hill aren't touching this issue with a
ten-foot pole they are completely silent
but on the campaign you're seeing how
this issue breaks out in the party with
Jeb Bush who wrote I believe the Supreme
Court should have allowed the states to
make this decision I also believe that
we should love our neighbor and respect
each other including making those the
lifetime commitments so this is what we
talked about beforehand where Jeb Bush
in this case specifically is going to
try and walk a careful line here he
believes this is a state's decision this
is this has always been his position on
this
however he well i wouldn't identify him
as a perfect just make anyway just make
it easier for him to go to his
republican backers and say look it might
be a close race for the Republican
nomination but I'm the candidate that
come with in a general election if you
want to dig in underneath the statements
here's what's actually going on here the
Republican the establishment area of the
Republican Party the big donors here in
Connecticut in DC in Florida on the
coast in California of the Republican
Party support same-sex marriage they
were crucial to New York's push on
same-sex marriage right
and so what Jeb Bush has done here is
he's figure out a way to say look
because of my religious beliefs this
isn't something I believe in
however this is the ruling this is what
the the highest court in the land has
stated and I'm gonna follow it and that
is something that he believes if you
talk to the Republican establishment
including the dozens that filed a brief
in support of this really high-level
folks a lot of Bush administration folks
this makes a lot of sense now there's
the other side the Republican Party the
side that is playing to religious
conservatives that is playing to
evangelicals
that's your Ted Cruz who as we mentioned
has a bill in Congress
to have a constitutional amendment to
ban same-sex marriage Bobby Jindal was
out with a very very strong statement
about an assault on religious liberty
that's the other segment of this and
that is that goes directly in line with
religious beliefs that goes directly in
line with being evangelicals but it also
goes into line with the politics that
they're trying to play in Iowa all right
Phil Mattingly thank you so much
fascinating to see how this all shakes
down and of course we'll get more
reaction from the different Republican
presidential candidates in the hours to
come following that historic Supreme
Court decision